alors vous savez les jeunes qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle avait là non
allez vous allez voir on le bouge
non c'est non
il est longiligne alors plus en plus une
rallonge bien alors ça s'appelle
l'interview alerte aux roses c'est tombé
sur vos haye quelle est votre première
pensée jeunes moreau lorsque vous
trouvez quand même et séduisant salut
jeune salah doit langage nous engager
est-ce que préféré draguer ou vous faire
draguer égaient les embrasser vous faire
embrasser en lead et les trains en même
temps caressé ou vous faire caresser
pareil largué ou faire larguer dernier
la galerie bull a calé quel est pour
vous le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
l'été à l'ombre l'hiver au chaud
quel est le lieu où vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour le space
mountain wayne rooney a prévu une
poubelle
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour de faire l'amour pour
aimer ça dépend des relations
des fois ça commence ça peut commencer
par le sexe et tenir de l'amour oui oui
d'accord
est ce que vous préférez attention c'est
très grave mais un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un infidèle ou un mec qui
baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
nina mille hommes ah bon j'en cherche un
troisième a été fidèle
alors sujets au sujet de l'adultère je
vous préférez pas savoir où tous n'y a
pas d'adultère savons que c'est un mot à
la fin du 19e siècle bon c'est juste
plus même une liaison préfère le mot
liaison non ça va ça vient tout ça
abondamment oui tu te souviens donc
voilà donc on n'en parle même pas on en
parle c'est pas n'existe pas manille
reuters et un tel cliché il ya deux ans
qu'ils foutent leur relation a l'air
pour ça ça vaut pas la peine de compter
un nouveau mot pour ça je sais pas non
on n'en parle pas c'est tout alors la
réponse est ce que vous conservez
dernière question un fantasme non
réalisés mais d'état ah oui vous pensez
les réaliser non justement ça va pas ah
ouais vous pensez que les pompeys procès
que c'est plus excitant de savoir et
vibrer c'est l'inatteignable c'est une
fois que c'est fait c'est fait